i've been around a long time but
hopefully i'll be around a lot longer we
pray for sure honey but how are you
going to celebrate this milestone
birthday
and commemorate it i've talked about
doing playboy cover
playboy again after 42 years well a
spokesperson for playboy tells e.t
we'd love to shoot dolly again she knows
that all she has to do
is say the word
i'm kind of a cartoon my look would be
the same when i'm 75 radio i'm sure
it'll still be
over exaggerated i'm not a natural
beauty mine's kind of all made up anyway
so i can just make it up more and more
as the years go by
we've spent a lot of years with miss
dolly
[Music]
i've always said i've got some brains
under this wig and a heart beneath these
boobs
welcome to pigeon pods entertainment
tonight
my dress is so tight i couldn't eat much
so after the show's over i'll
let my zipper down and eat like a pig
the best advice is just be true to
yourself know your own talents know your
own strengths and weaknesses
and don't sell out to nobody for no
reason
[Applause]
the always sassy dolly had a sweet witch
for her birthday today
posting a call for kindness and
unearthing love
she's been married to the love of her
life carl dean for 54 years
they never had kids but dolly has no
regrets i always look at it like i
didn't have kids so everybody's kids
could be mine
was there any point in over the course
of your career
that you ever considered adoption yeah i
thought about it
but i didn't really need to because i
had a house full angelina and brad you
know they adopted
i'd like to adopt brad pitt